is arguably the world's biggest robotics
company did you catch that let me save
you the stress of rewinding elon just
called tesla arguably the biggest
robotics company well he didn't just say
it he said it last year in august during
the tesla ai day when he also announced
the company's plans to make a humanoid
robot prototype called optimus available
this year tesla's optimus subprime so
many people myself included thought that
this tesla bot prototype promise was
just another one of elon's exaggerated
timelines today my take
teslabot
probably won't exist anytime soon either
you know i know they said on stage there
would be a prototype maybe next year
i
uh
i kind of doubt pretty soon because last
august he gave a very unexpected
timeline for when we'll see one of these
we think we'll probably have
a prototype sometime next year
roll the clip
autonomous rover taxis tesla next year
uh next year i mean it's looking quite
likely that it will be next year but
maybe that's not fair
and there's good technological reasons
for that as we'll see later in this
video but despite the many rolled eyes
and murmurs musk might actually come
good this time knock on wood on june 3rd
the man tweeted that not only is a
prototype likely to be available it's
also the reason that this year's tesla
ai day was moved from august 19th to
september 30th he added that the first
prototype would not look anything like
the display model shown during the ai
day last year and also during the cyber
rodeo event at the giga texas
manufacturing facility with that model
it was designed with lightweight
materials stands at five foot eight and
weighs 125 pounds the robot has a face
with a screen for useful information two
axis feet for balancing and force
feedback sensing on the ankles 40
electromechanical actuators for motion
around the joints and the one i actually
do struggle to believe human level hands
beyond the mechanical build up the robot
also has features for ai machine
learning and deep learning features like
the autopilot cameras fsd monitors auto
labeling multicam video neural networks
and neural net planning and perhaps most
importantly dojo training but more on
that in a minute the scary part of the
presentation came when elon said this
we're setting it such that it is um
at a mechanical level at a physical
level uh you can run away from it
and and most likely overpower it
so
hopefully that doesn't ever happen but
um you never know geez okay elon we
really needed to hear that anyways the
robot would have a top speed of 5 miles
per hour a deadlift of 150 pounds and a
carry capacity of 45 pounds but let's
get back to what i asked at the very
beginning where elon called tesla a
robotics company instead of an electric
car company is tesla truly a robotics
company first let's differentiate
between robotics and regular machines
and engineering when you or i use the
word robots or robotics we're talking
about machines that can mimic the
actions of sentient beings in the case
of humanoid robots they can substitute
for humans and replicate our actions
right is there anything of that sort
that we know tesla built like that yes
their cars you see of almost any car
company worldwide today tesla has the
best software for dynamically mapping
and recognizing its environment and it's
this that also puts it front and center
of autonomous driving technology plus
the high resolution mapping display on
the screen is just a chef's kiss teslas
have eight cameras providing a 360
degree field of view as well as a radar
and ultrasonic sensors for perfect
mapping of the environment combined with
bleeding edge computer vision machine
learning and deep learning technology
these vehicles are able to automatically
label and evolve to navigate new terrain
based on information from cameras and
sensors what's more they upload the data
from all the miles driven back to the
network for the rest of the fleet
essentially this system is like a hive
mind training itself to get better and
the vehicles and their data are like the
brain cells neurons and electrical
signals therefore the bigger it gets the
more instances to evolve on and the
better it gets you see navigation is a
key action most sentient beings possess
and tesla is the closest thing we have
to a machine doing it autonomously while
constantly recognizing new things in the
surrounding basically if you think about
what we're doing right now with the cars
tesla is arguably the world's biggest
robotics company because our cars are
like
semi-sentient robots on wheels so if the
tesla bot is basically the tesla vehicle
transformed into a different form factor
the humanoid form then optimus subprime
is pretty accurate but before i play
devil's advocate let me show you why
many experts haven't backed optimus what
critics are saying so the reception for
the tesla bot was not flattering like i
said even i had a lot of reservations
about it and elon's timeline and grand
descriptions didn't help either and i
think a part of that is because all the
robotics companies today are not
promising what he and tesla are
promising take boston dynamics for
example they're like the leading actual
robotics company out there and despite
the impressive stunts they've made it
clear that a working model is not likely
to be out anytime soon the robots still
have a lot to learn
another criticism is that the human form
is not an ideal form for robots a lot of
experts agree that the best way to build
a robot for a task is to make it
specific enough to that task like a
vacuum cleaning robot is better as the
actual vacuum cleaner a cloth folder is
better as this thing flipping it on it
pulls it in
does its thing and spits out a folded
shirt
right at the bottom there
and even a dishwasher is a good example
too in those instances you wouldn't want
to build a humanoid robot to drive
around a vacuum or be the folding
machine or do the dishes those specific
robots do the job and what is more you
don't have a humanoid shaped robot
sitting in your car driving the car for
you the car
is the robot the self-driving car that
drives itself has already been done
another point of skepticism regards some
technological points concerning
articulation battery life and balance
and when it comes to articulation
concerns i'm one of those skeptics
because like i said earlier human level
hands are pretty damn difficult a
fingertip has at least 3 000 touch
receptors and connected to a brain you
and i are likely to slightly tap a box
before carrying it just to gauge its
weight if we didn't do that like a robot
we could smash objects or exert so much
force that we would fall over speaking
of falling over senior director of
robotics research at boston dynamics
scott kindesma had this to say about
atlas falls that i showed you guys
earlier if you or i were to vault over a
barrier we would take advantage of
certain properties of our bodies that
would not translate to the robot
properties like our spine that lets us
bend our torso and body and properties
like the excellent weight distribution
atlas doesn't have and with battery life
it's noteworthy that top robots like
atlas use lithium-ion batteries and have
battery lives of about two hours while
taking about the same time to charge is
the tesla bot bound to fail
now allow me to play devil's advocate as
promised by addressing the criticisms
the first is the fact that other
robotics companies aren't quote unquote
over-promising like elon and tesla in
fact tesla isn't the first car company
to do something like this as honda has
done this with what the website
describes as the world's most advanced
humanoid robot as semo and so it seems
everyone has had a head start ahead of
tesla and they're still nowhere near
putting up products by 2023 as elon has
claimed for tesla and this is why i
think that is pay close attention most
of these robots can be classified into
the neck up and neck down categories so
you could say atlas or spot from boston
dynamics are more geared neck down
robots with the focus on robot
kinematics
still freaking impressive and for the
neck up robots you could find ones like
amica from engineered arts or sofia from
hanson robotics these robots are more
about interacting with humans i would
argue that tesla however uses an inside
out approach or back end to front-end
approach in the sense of what elon once
called asic everything this means
building application-specific integrated
circuits to get the best performance for
a system in other words the teslabot has
an upper hand because of the already
existing neural network and dojo
training that has been good for its
self-driving vehicles tesla has
supervised most of the technology for
this robot using technology specific for
the system and use cases they envision
unlike the other robotics and automotive
companies which for instance use
ready-made chips from nvidia or intel
that are general purpose and serve a
wide range of applications tesla's fsd
chip however has been built specifically
for its self-driving technology and even
more specific is the dojo supercomputer
which it announced on the same day
optimus was announced and this dojo d1
chip probably deserves its own video in
the future but the bottom line is that
it has a lot of computing power never
seen before in a vehicle this computing
power will improve computer vision
machine learning and neural networking
several times over and basically the
tesla bottom vehicles will become much
better navigators they will basically
have a brain in the form of a neural
network for adapting recognizing and
navigating around objects which is the
best rebuttal for the human form
argument i stated earlier the tesla bot
is built to remove repetitive boring and
dangerous tasks or more accurately to do
anything you don't want to do the human
form is efficient for one thing
navigation we're not the best at any one
thing can walk run swim glide climb
mountains and so much more for
navigating the natural world we have
probably done it the best and in the
home even if you had a vacuum robot or
cloth folder or dishwasher you still
need to take the dirt out of the vacuum
cleaner you still need to hang the
clothes into the cloth folder and you
still need to arrange the plates even
from taking out the trash to arranging
the grocery bags in your car boot if the
tesla bot can navigate anything properly
it'd save a lot of time and be efficient
for labor this is what elon said when
talking about the differences between
machines and humans in tesla factories
really good at adaptation
and rapid evolution and like doing
like little like
finicky things like like that um it's
like like trying to connect uh a hose
that that's like sort of dangling around
go ah they're done gotcha yeah grabbing
the wrong thing and like to stick it
over here and it's like oh the the hose
was here when the rover thought it was
here and so now it like tries to grab
air and then like smashes into the car
battery articulation and balance i am
eager to see what tesla does for a good
battery it's important because like i
mentioned earlier with boston dynamics
atlas things like a heavy battery can
cause uneven weight distribution and
distort balance lithium-ion battery
packs will probably do that but they
might find a way around it alternatives
like the zinc air battery which can be
structural by being built into the frame
of the robot nikolas kotov from the
university of michigan has also been
experimenting on biomorphic batteries
using kevlar the bulletproof vest
material and he says it can produce 72
times more energy than a single
lithium-ion battery what is interesting
about these alternatives is that they
resemble the way we humans store energy
reserves in fatty tissues under our skin
and if applied they also help with the
center of gravity of the root by not
adding a lot of weight that conventional
battery packs add thus balance is also
resolved using a structural battery like
those i just mentioned maybe that also
has something to do with elon saying
that the prototype displayed at the next
ai day will look nothing like previous
display models and as for articulation i
have absolutely no idea how they're
going to make that happen and now is
probably the time to say that everything
i've said so far is speculation seeing
as i'm not an expert and i know experts
will be in the comments telling me what
was said wrongly but the truth is that
many people believe that the ai day last
year was elon's way of recruiting top
talent for other projects while getting
publicity i mean rumors are going around
that they've been working with robotics
guru dennis hong so who wouldn't want to
work with these guys whatever they come
up with we'll have to wait and see for
30th of september or just find out that
it's yet again another unrealistic
timeline by our dear friend mr musk hey
if you enjoyed this one you'll probably
enjoy this one on the screen too so why
don't you click it